Trascrizione: Angela Di Croce
Revisore: Ysiana Agalliu
Voglio parlarvi di tecnologia.
Normalmente quando parliamo di tecnologia
tutti noi abbiamo due atteggiamenti.
Il primo è un po’ come...
Avete presente i film di fantascienza
hollywoodiani degli anni ’40 e ’50?
Sì, la guerra dei mondi.
È qualche cosa fuori di noi
che arriva a un certo punto,
nel migliore dei casi ci vuole dominare,
nel peggiore distruggere.
Qualche cosa che arriva.
“Oddio, c’è questa cosa tecnologica”.
Il secondo approccio, invece, è molto
più positivo, è l’uomo vitruviano
di Leonardo da Vinci, l’uomo perfettamente
inserito nella natura, armonico,
che con la matematica e la geometria,
con la scienza, con la tecnologia,
crea una serie di dispositivi fuori da sé,
con cui domina il mondo
e non ne viene dominato.
Quindi, uscendo dalla paura
dell’uomo delle caverne.
Io vi voglio proporre un terzo,
una terza via
che deriva da un racconto
di Edgar Allan Poe.
Si chiama Il giocatore
di scacchi di Maelzel.
Allora ne Il giocatore di scacchi
di Maelzel, Edgar Allan Poe fa se stesso,
cioè fa il giornalista.
A un certo punto arriva negli Stati Uniti
questo automa molto particolare
realizzato nel Seicento da Maelzel.
Maelzel era un costruttore di orologi,
di meccanismi di precisione e di automi.
Il giocatore di scacchi è una scatola
particolarmente grossa,
piena di marchingegni,
di automazioni e via dicendo.
Sopra è appoggiato un mezzobusto
dalle fattezze orientali.
Viene chiamato “il turco” proprio perché
ha il turbante, ha i baffi.
Sul corpo dell’automa due braccia
semovibili. Davanti a sé una scacchiera.
Il giocatore di scacchi di Maelzel gioca
a scacchi in autonomia. Particolare.
Edgar Allan Poe però non si fida.
Va a guardare, scopre che nella gabbiotta
che c’è sotto, meccanismi di specchi
celano un antro e in quell’antro
c’è un uomo che muove le braccia.
La morale qual è?
Che in ogni tecnologia
c’è dentro un uomo, c’è l’essere umano.
Noi siamo la tecnologia.
Questo vale ancora di più per la
tecnologia digitale,
perché la tecnologia digitale,
fin da subito,
si smarca dall’essere qualcosa
che viene usato.
Non è la leva, la clava, il cannocchiale,
non è uno strumento per fare qualche cosa.
Fin dagli esordi, fin dai padri fondatori,
il matematico Alan Turing,
già negli anni ’40, quando progetta
il primo computer digitale,
parla del computer
come se si trattasse di un ragazzo.
Dice “ha bisogno di una memoria,
di un training, deve avere un’educazione”.
“Gli mettiamo dentro dei dati, delle
informazioni e vedrete che cresce
e diventa una macchina universale”.
Cioè una macchina
che sa fare qualsiasi calcolo.
Per dimostrare che la macchina che
ha inventato è il computer che lui pensa,
inventa un test, lo chiama
il test di Turing, l’Imitation Game.
In una stanza scura si fa una domanda,
arriva una risposta e bisogna capire
se quella risposta è arrivata
da una macchina o da un essere umano.
Se è indistinguibile, ecco, quella
è la macchina di Turing, capite?
Lo strumento non è qualcosa
che serve a fare qualche cosa,
ma è qualcosa che imita l’essere umano.
Negli anni ’50, John von Neumann
sugli appunti di Turing
costruisce il primo computer digitale
e parla di questo computer usando
delle metafore di biologia,
parla di cervello artificiale,
di biologia artificiale.
Addirittura giocando anche un po’
per assurdo, dice che siamo noi,
è il nostro cervello che funziona in
maniera digitale e funziona per algoritmi.
Per provare che il cervello digitale,
il cervello artificiale,
può essere biologico,
può avere delle funzioni biologiche,
si inventa un giochino
per mostrare la complessità.
Si chiama automa cellulare.
È questo qua.
Guardate ancora una volta
le metafore biologiche.
Che cos’è?
È una griglia con dei quadrati,
alcuni bianchi, alcuni neri.
Si parte da fermi, si danno
una serie di indicazioni sul tempo.
In un tot di tempo, 10 secondi,
le caselle nere si devono spostare
di due posti, per esempio,
e di conseguenza le bianche
si devono spostare anche loro.
Viene fatto partire
e questo va in loop automatico.
Neumann scopre che questo loop
mima i processi biologici,
va oltre quello che ci si aspettava
dalle prime indicazioni
e diventa davvero
una macchina biologica artificiale.
Sempre negli anni ’50, Norbert Wiener
fonda una dottrina, una disciplina.
La chiama cibernetica.
La cibernetica sapete che cos’è ?
È la costruzione di comunicazioni
quindi trasferimenti di informazioni
tra uomini, esseri umani,
animali e macchine.
Per la prima volta sono accomunati
nello stesso ecosistema
enti biologici e non biologici.
Negli anni ’60,
un altro matematico, Joseph Licklider,
sta studiando in quel momento
come fare a collegare i computer,
quello che poi diventerà
Arpanet e poi Internet.
Parla di simbiosi uomo macchina,
ritorna alla biologia.
La simbiosi è quando due animali convivono
e la loro convivenza
porta alla sopravvivenza.
Uno aiuta l'altro a sopravvivere.
Qua per la prima volta la simbiosi
è tra un bios, l’essere umano,
e un non bios, la macchina.
È cambiato qualche cosa,
perché con la simbiosi,
con l’idea di simbiosi
cambia completamente tutto.
Ma non è soltanto l'idea della simbiosi.
È anche il fatto
che stanno cambiando i modelli.
Se ci pensate tutte le filosofie,
i pensieri che stanno prima,
che anticipano, che precedono,
che sostengono la cultura digitale,
vanno in questa direzione biologica.
Pensate alla teoria cyborg.
Philip K. Dick,
i romanzi di fantascienza, Blade Runner,
William Gibson che si immagina
le interfacce neurali.
E poi il postumanesimo, il transumanesimo.
Sono tutte teorie,
la teoria cyborg appunto,
ripresa anche dai movimenti femministi,
che parlano del digitale come di un’entità
biologica, cioè di somiglianza all’umano.
Qualche anno fa mi chiesero per una mostra
importante sulla cultura digitale,
di portare un oggetto che fosse
emblematico della cultura digitale.
Ecco, io non ebbi alcun dubbio
e portai questa cosa qua.
Il Tamagotchi. Lo ricordate il Tamagotchi?
Quella roba stupidissima.
Negli anni ’90 tutti andavamo pazzi
per il Tamagotchi, arrivava dal Giappone.
Ma perché?
Perché il Tamagotchi portava in sé alcuni
elementi chiave della cultura digitale.
Intanto la computer grafica, che se notate
è molto simile agli automi cellulari, no?
La pixelation del quadro. Poi aveva
un’altra caratteristica era interattivo.
Il computer da subito nasce
come interattivo, i feedback.
Se dobbiamo dialogare è ovvio
che deve dirci qualche cosa.
Era portatile.
Pensate come la storia del computer
è anche questa
una storia di avvicinamento
al nostro corpo.
Prima erano quei computer
che occupavano intere stanze.
Poi si è messo sulla scrivania,
poi nello zainetto, poi in tasca.
Adesso sul polso.
È sempre più vicino al nostro corpo.
È sempre più una simbiosi
con il nostro corpo.
Ecco, forse non ci innamoreremo
dei computer, come succede nel film Her.
Ve lo ricordate?
Anche se sono usciti degli articoli
negli Stati Uniti e in Giappone di persone
che si sono innamorate del loro
software di intelligenza artificiale.
Ecco, forse non arriveremo a questo.
Però intanto abbiamo già demandato
molte cose a queste macchine.
Gli chiediamo di scegliere
o di consigliarci le serie da vedere,
i film da vedere, di indicizzare
le nostre ricerche in internet.
Di aiutarci negli acquisti.
Parliamoci chiaro, fino a qualche anno fa
il massimo che facevamo di simbiosi con
un artificio tecnico era quando
compravamo l’automobile
e c’era il mese di rodaggio,
ve lo ricordate?
Adesso voi non acquistate
uno smartphone, no.
Voi lo adottate, lo scegliete con cura.
Vi confrontate, lo personalizzate.
Mettete alcune app, demandate a lui.
La comunicazione, la memoria,
lo tenete sempre con voi.
È lui che vi sveglia la mattina,
è lui che vi dice se c’è una riunione,
è un dialogo, è un dialogo serrato.
Prima vi parlavo degli automi cellulari,
vi ricordate la griglia?
Ma non sono diversi,
anzi, quella è la radice
dei software che stanno facendo
tanto parlare di loro in queste settimane,
quelli di intelligenza artificiale
cosiddetta generativa.
Che cosa sono per chi se li ha persi?
Niente di particolare.
Sono dei software a cui si danno
delle indicazioni e questi generano
automaticamente dei testi di risposta.
Quali testi mi chiederete? Di tutto.
Immagini, video,
testi scritti, articoli di giornale.
Vi do una dritta? I compiti
dei vostri figli, tanto per capirci.
Ecco, quello è il mondo
della tecnologia digitale.
Allora, molto probabilmente,
dobbiamo smetterla di occuparci del lato
semplicemente tecnico e meccanico
della tecnologia digitale
e occuparci del lato più umano.
Dobbiamo metterci etica.
Le discipline umanistiche.
Dobbiamo essere responsabili delle nostre
tecnologie perché sono lo specchio nostro.
Anzi, vi ricordate Edgar Allan Poe?
Se noi siamo la tecnologia,
prenderci cura della tecnologia
significa prenderci cura di noi stessi.
Vi ringrazio.
(Applausi)